ahorita quiero hacer una pequeña
continuación del vídeo pasado porque no
termine con las herramientas fiscales
que tiene el gobierno a su disposición
para desplazar la curva de demanda
agregada hacia la derecha en el vídeo
pasado únicamente vimos la situación en
la cual el gobierno dejaba los impuestos
fijos y dijimos que aumentaba el gasto
la única forma en la cual podía hacer
esto era financiarse con deuda aunque en
realidad también si es un gobierno que
tiene muchos ahorros podría aumentar
este gran gasto ahorrando menos eso es
un poco fuera de lo común pero también
podría ser así ahorita quiero ver la
posibilidad de modificar los impuestos
pero antes déjame explicar esta
situación del vídeo pasado en términos
de los componentes del producto interno
bruto si ahí tenemos producto interno
bruto es igual al consumo más la
inversión más el gasto de gobierno más
la exportación neta aquí lo del consumo
casi todo era hecho por individuos
verdad es lo que la gente va y gasta en
el súper y en los muchos otros lugares
la inversión era las empresas en que
invertían casi todo esto tenía que ver
con empresas y tal vez con algunos
individuos que hacen sus casas
aquí tenemos el gasto gubernamental y la
exportación neta y esto completa todo el
panorama verdad ahora qué sucede si el
impuesto está fijo pues este caso de acá
esta parte permanece constante permanece
constante de modo que cuando el gobierno
gasta verdad aumenta su gasto pues tiene
que endeudarse por otro lado pero este
de aquí va para arriba y el producto
interno bruto va para arriba y eso causa
que la curva de demanda agregada se vaya
para la derecha bueno esta es una forma
de hacer las cosas pero el gobierno
tiene otra forma de desplazar la curva
hacia la derecha a través de los
impuestos déjame ponerle por acá otra
vez el gobierno el gobierno y entonces
ahora lo que puede hacer el gobierno es
ahora dejamos el gasto igual el gasto se
mantiene constante déjame lo pongo con
otro color
le voy a poner el gasto
se mantiene constante pero ahora lo que
va a hacer el gobierno es disminuir los
impuestos impuestos los impuestos van
para abajo a esta entonces qué sucede
ahora en términos del producto interno
bruto y de sus componentes otra vez
tenemos que el producto interno bruto es
igual al consumo más la inversión más el
gasto gubernamental más la exportación
pero ahora el gobierno mantiene el gasto
fijo verdad mantiene el gasto de aquí
fijo pero esta parte de acá va a
aumentar el consumo y la inversión
porque porque habrá el gobierno está
requiriendo menos dinero de las de los
individuos y de las empresas que está
requiriendo menos dinero de los
individuos de y de las empresas tienen
más dinero para gastarlo tienen más
dinero para invertir y de nuevo la
demanda agregada va hacia la derecha
otra vez la única forma en la cual el
gobierno puede financiar esto cómo está
disminuyendo su fuente de ingresos de de
impuestos es a través de deuda o bien
ahorrando menos ok entonces nada más
quería decirte esto quería
a comentarte que la política fiscal no
únicamente tiene que ver con un aumento
de gasto sino que también tiene que ver
con algunas políticas en términos de
impuestos